take a look at this from many Johnson
he tweeted this earlier breaking Fulton
County D.A Fanny Willis regularly
questioned election results and used her
office to push unfounded conspiracies on
the eve of Trump's arrest in Georgia for
challenging an election a deep dive into
the prosecutor's history of doing the
same thing here's one post he said
Georgia could determine who is our next
president a team of lawyers needs to
watch them count every single vote they
can start in Fulton where we are having
water leaks what ballots are they
throwing out Georgia let's give an
honest accounting no stunts
he goes on a mansion a deep dive shows
that she is a hard and radical activist
not an unbiased attorney her page is
littered with BLM propaganda
Fulton County D.A Fannie Willis
blatantly and quite illegally used her
office for partisan political activity
imagine thinking you'll get just from a
person who is a proud Democrat there you
go with the mug father is a black
panther
really you didn't know that yes her
father was literally a black panther you
know the people who ran around with the
Weather Underground those folks
every for the past 10 years we've heard
people screaming and freaking out about
like Nazis and the right and blah blah
and yet the organizations that were
actually mailing bombs around the United
States in the 60s and 70s well all of
their progeny all of the children of
that movement all of the people that
were informed by the thinkers of that
movement those people are in positions
of power and in positions of authority
and Academia and they're making New
Radicals and they're there still bill
there's still teaching in Chicago and
still writing Obama's book
everything is fine don't worry about it
they're not radical at all the the
amount of of red washing that has
happened to America uh to Americans is
ridiculous and and
even with
like McCarthyism in the 50s and stuff
and still there's been a massive amount
of red Washings
like Pro communism people just like
hiding or or downplaying communist
influence and and communist Theory and
stuff like that and and
talking about communist Theory or like
you know leftist Theory and stuff like
that but not telling people where it
comes from that it or making the
connection to the thinkers that so like
they'll they'll talk about like say the
in the influence was this this person
right but they don't tell you that this
person's uh their their uh Mentor or
whatever was someone like Angela Davis
or someone like Mark Herbert Marquis or
whatever people that are well known as
leftist thinkers I can't remember his
name but the CIA director
no they're really nasty one you look
like a bulldog if you hold up a
photograph of him he looks like a
bulldog he literally voted for the
Communists yeah he was a communist yeah
that's I was and I think I think he
voted for Angela Davis probably he was
yeah he was Communist so well one of my
favorite examples of this was uh there
was a couple years ago a non-profit it
wasn't the ADL but some like research
group put out a study on domestic
terrorism and they said you know right
wing extremism white supremacy is is
what's leading the country in domestic
terrorism but they wouldn't release the
data that they used they they wouldn't
release it so anyone could verify it and
they also excluded any environmental
terrorism so anything like whether
underground they didn't count and so the
the data that they're working off of is
inaccurate but then they report the
headline to freak people out they want
you to be misled on purpose and I think
that's the biggest issue that the
average American has which is that they
don't have time to comb through
everything and so they end up relying on
the headlines and the headlines are
based on false information and Elon Musk
said they're going to get rid of
headlines on X and I think it's a
brilliant idea yep so I don't know
exactly how they do it but I'm assuming
that means when you post a link it's
just going to show the body of text not
the headline
yeah because what they tried doing first
was it was like you didn't read the
article would you like to read the
article first which I liked what I love
is uh I'll give you an example The Daily
Beast ran a fake story claiming that I
was said Tim Paul was accused of
stealing a cat the real story was random
person lies police confirm lie we ran
headline anyway
and so this is what they do you make a
headline Twitter at the time before it
was X put the story in the what's
happening page for like two weeks and it
was the weirdest thing I'm like what
what is this and then the story at the
bottom it's like police confirm it's not
true and they're alike but we'll put the
headline anyway well that's my question
because
if you're going to do the body of the
the story I want it to be paragraph
eight if possible yeah because if you
read the articles usually the Articles
the first couple paragraphs line up with
the headline and as you keep reading the
second half of the article disproves the
entire First Steps welcome to Modern
journalism right but so which part are
you going to actually clip as the
preview which is a complete nightmare
are you gonna do three random sentences
which could be interesting or one it's
just the opening paragraph because
you'll you won't get full contacts it'll
just say something like today Donald
Trump had appeared at the Fulton County
courthouse and Dot
well there's such lighters don't say
um shameful guilty scumbag president
showed up I mean they literally are just
trying to figure it out yeah yep yeah I
love the uh the fact Checkers trick the
classical move where they'll do
something like
you know Donald Trump will do a backflip
off of the White House and land
perfectly and then Snopes will write did
Donald Trump do a backflip perfectly off
of the White House onto the lawn on
Sunday and then they'll put false and
then they'll give you this big
long-winded explanation and very all at
the bottom say well he did do a backflip
it was on Saturday
and so they add context to a story that
no one offered and then claim it was
false because the context they add I
love it I'll give you another example
actually is uh Biden falling asleep
you saw that video you mean he's bowing
his head in solemnity solemnity if Biden
falls asleep and what do what does
everyone say he's falling asleep he
appears to have fallen asleep yeah for
like 10 seconds and then obviously in
the video he gets back up I counted it
it's 10 seconds then his eyes open he
coughs and then he looks up and I said
he looks like he's falling asleep what
did NBC News claim they claimed that we
said he was sleeping outright they said
he'd no he's not that well we never said
that he pulled out a pillow laid down on
the ground took a nap said he was
falling asleep he clearly is and they're
like in the high resolution video you
can see that he opens his eyes and it's
like we all you got us we're we're
totally misleading you but they lie
they claim what we've said was more
extreme than what we actually said and
then fact check us it's just absolutely
insane also couldn't like I think you
tweeted about this but
a lot of people doze off in meetings
while sitting still especially people
who travel and work a lot like he didn't
snap on the ground like these things
happen instead they freaked out and both
said you guys are lying also he was
being very respectful like he's just
really old and probably should not be
living the lifestyle that he's being
forced to live right like that's it and
you guys should accept it but they can't
because they can't admit anything is
wrong with Joe Biden because he's their
incumbent and they have to protect him
at all costs like they're they're doing
a lot of crazy stuff to Republicans but
Progressive left they were controlling
the the Biden White House are also in a
terrible position they do not have a
strong candidate going into 2024 that's
why they're so desperate
well they do have a guy who's kind of
running around and we're still trying to
figure that out why is Gavin Newsom
running around the country campaigning
without actually campaigning isn't it we
know where it's going what did Trump say
about Gavin Newsom the other day on the
Tucker interview
it's like I always actually really got
along with them we'll see it's gonna be
interesting yeah I think
I think it's reasonable to say Biden is
somehow removed from the race in one way
or another and then Gavin Newsom steps
in my my my my theory I don't know if
you heard what I was saying about this a
few weeks ago the best way for Democrats
to pull it off is for Joe Biden to have
a medical episode on stage at a
California rally where Newsom is acting
as a surrogate and then Newsome Runs Out
rolls up his sleeves and does CPR and
Joe Biden saving his life Joe Biden then
says you know the the difficulty in the
strain has been too much for me and I
can't you know blah blah blah but Gavin
Newsom has proven he's the man for the
nation he does a press tour everyone
says you saved the president's life what
is that like and he's just like you know
you got to do your duty in this country
that's that's PR gold you you could not
hire someone pay someone there's no
amount of money that would give you the
historic PR I have to imagine honestly
too if that really did go down that way
Joe Biden has some kind of medically
faints or something and then there's
panic and everyone's screaming and like
we we've all seen him trip but like so
they're primed for it a more serious
thing where like grips his chest and
then he stumbles down and falls and the
crowd gasps then Gavin Newsom runs out
and saves his life
his his favorability goes up to like 63
his approval rating among Democrats goes
up to 99.9 he then says you know I never
wanted to take the job this is not my
intention or my plan but I will not let
you down Joe and Joe's going to be like
thank you except for Kamala is going to
be on the side that's with the with an
ax going no I don't think so unless the
Supreme Court Justice happens to be
removed at the right time she's not
going to go away quietly because she's
part of the alternative action in
California but I think I I think she
does as she's told and the question
actually is how do you get past Kamala
because if we're going in order of
succession in any normal political uh
circumstance if Biden is out for any
reason Kamala is next no she's there I
mean the second he stops she's there so
he has to but say I'm not running again
but stay alive long enough for it so
what happens is Biden doesn't leave
office he says you know while I'm
recovering I think it's fair to say that
I will not see re-election due to the
you know the concerns that people have
for my health but I believe Gavin Newsom
is that proven leader and Kamala will
agree you cannot beat that PR I don't I
don't see any other way they remove
Kamala from the equation without looking
really weird and clumsy well to build
off your theory uh uh chief justice
Breyers is retiring at the end of this
term right so theoretically they could
say Kamala you get to be on the Supreme
Court like to your point this is
actually happening Alphas yeah and
she'll be like I don't need to run
president I'm gonna stay in the Supreme
Court forever I think Gavin Newsom is
like great great I will become president
nominate you yep um or Joe Biden I guess
if he's around depending on when his you
know medical emergency happens I mean we
really do have this set up where it
could work all the Supreme Court's
justices get lobbied to stay or not stay
depending on what benefits the rest of
the party Kamala could say something
like you know I was here for Joe
and you know with everything that's
going on I am overwhelmed and or she
stays on his VP and says I think being
the vice president and having Gavin step
in is is is fine I have a two-term VP
that'd be crazy I cannot see that
because from 100 she and Gavin are not
tight so Supreme Court Justice I could
see them giving her that I mean that's
life but that means he needs a different
VP and she has to leave for some reason
but but I agree I mean it's it's I I
can't think of a scenario in which they
can successfully
have Biden not run
and if they don't then Kamala doesn't
run they've got barricades here yeah
Biden is they have no choice what are
they gonna do if they pull him out it
looks weak and it's uncertainty and
people are scared of it
at the very least they might lose votes
Trump might not gain votes they might
lose votes if Biden's out then it's
going to become left it's not common
with what's happening like how do you
how do you have Biden and Kamala not be
running at all and it's Gavin in someone
else well and Biden said explicitly you
know one of his his goals was to have uh
you know more diverse people
representing the party at the federal
level so to a certain extent people are
expecting to become for a lot of reasons
she just didn't work out the way they
wanted her to like she would never
pulled in a popular way she does not
have the Charisma to carry off the
presidency uh but if they can Shuffle
her off they can power broker her into
the Supreme Court maybe they'll be able
to pull someone up from the bench I
think Gavin Newsom will have challenges
all the time because I think the
Democratic party does is sort of split
on the face that they'd like to see in
the white house but he is the only
person on their bench after the two
current president and vice president and
he's gonna debate is he still debating
his hands what's up with that I think so
which is weird I mean think about that
for a second because again he's not
running but we do have precedent
remember I said 1968. right yep well
what did we have in 1968 an extremely
corrupt president who did not have the
best health who stepped out of the race
and then we had a Robert F Kennedy enter
the race and take over so
LBJ and Biden are really similar there's
a lot of parallels there the corruption
the family money the TV station and uh
and how long was Kennedy in before LBJ
uh
two three years yeah yeah like was not a
full presidential like run so you get
Trump in for a year and then Biden steps
in so there are other similarities in
the duration
politico's reporting that the Gavin
Newsom Ron DeSantis debate is at an
impasse because of issues Fox is having
so it was planned for November but I
guess it's like maybe not gonna happen
Okay Gavin Ron come on down we'll do it
we'll turn the camera on and go live
culture war no but in all seriousness
it'd be cool if we did but how hard is
it for them to turn on a webcam and be
like let's talk no they have to use
mainstream media too otherwise you're a
fringe right-wing candidate that's right
that's right from I understand DeSantis
isn't going around on podcasts anywhere
so he's finally learning I guess now but
he seemed to be allergic to it oh man
Vivek is hitting the nail on the head
with the hammer he's been going on every
podcast he can he went on Alex Stein's
live show and that got asked about 911
they're using that against him yeah but
vivek's just like I'll go on anyone's
show like let's get the word out I think
the fake understands the balkanization
of media spaces and Bobby Kennedy
absolutely yeah both of them uh I mean
oh yeah podcasts are going to play a
huge role yeah in this election yes
obviously I can't remember if it was
vague or Larry Elder that week that we
had both of them on but one of them was
talking about doing the podcast like a
podcast style thing like fireside chat
from the Oval Office like it is cool to
see these people Embrace new media
especially as we can see I don't know
that fox will ever go completely away
all entirely but it doesn't have the
power it used to thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time